today on stick to football we're gonna
have some fun happy Valentine's Day by
the way we're gonna go through some cash
or trash NFL rumors we don't look back
the 2017 draft answer your draft on
draft questions but we want to start
this off with some good news and some
bad news
so good news we have our Indianapolis
Meetup booked February 29th 2 p.m. at
tootsie Brewing Company the same place
we've been the last two years so if
you're gonna be an Andy for the combine
or if you live in the Indianapolis area
we're gonna hand out a couple free beers
to everybody who comes in so come check
that out now the bad news Monday is
President's Day and we're gonna do
something we've never done on stick to
football we are taking a holiday and not
like the Peppa Pig British kind but
we're taking a holiday day off be our
Studios closed I am getting out of town
if the banks aren't open we're not oh so
no stick to football Monday I know that
one dude who left the iTunes review
where he lost his [ __ ] can we get a
wellness check on that guy before Monday
hopefully he has a good Valentine's Day
because no show Monday but then
Wednesday will be back and I'd say a
week of the combine we're gonna be
throwing so much material at you guys
that you won't even know what to do with
yourself so that is those are all the
notes I have let's jump into the show
Mel O'Connor myself check us out on BRS
YouTube page you can watch us do the
show or listen here like you do on a
podcast stitch or Spotify wherever you
are guys miles Garrett is back not like
Texas back he's officially back miles
Garrett reinstated by Commissioner Roger
Goodell I don't think he'd ever so
surprised that he's been reinstated
maybe just surprised by when it happened
I'd have a dead period here yeah but I
think the recency bias of when it first
happened with the helmet incident
everybody was calling for this guy's
career so I do like the fact that they
suspended him indefinitely and then
revisited in January February the six
games that he missed for the rest of the
year I think that was enough I think
that Miles Garrett probably learned his
lesson I definitely don't think we'll
see him do it again so to have him back
to start the season if you're a Browns
fan you've got to just be absolutely
pumped to have this guy pack for the
full season and I think the NFL did the
right thing here the six game suspension
reinstate him let him have his off see
and get out in front of it you don't
have to worry about it and like you said
there's a little bit of a dead period
here why not keep your name in the in
the spotlight if you're the NFL bring
back one of your star players it felt
like a really out of character moment to
four-mile scary and I know that doesn't
forgive all but I think when you're
looking at
I guess the lack of severity of this
punishment you know it doesn't extend
into next year I think that really
played into it miles Garrett having such
a clean background before something like
this so I'm glad he's back and somebody
else back with the Browns now or joining
the Browns Ryan Greeks in is officially
back in the NFL and will advise Andrew
berry so an old face returns to the
Browns and now a new face
not a hire that I'm super pumped up
about guys but it's one that they
clearly feel strong about over there I
wonder how Gregson will do not be in the
GM like if he can just scout consult
yeah yeah just do what he did that got
him that Colts job back in the day if he
can do that I have been a little hard on
the Browns because they have this
structure with a lot of people who don't
have college scouting experience so I
think it's a positive to go get someone
who does have some experience in that
but Ryan Grigson not not gonna warm any
hearts when you talk about best GM's
ever yeah I mean ruin danger luck and
just the hires that are going on in
Cleveland it's hard to get behind
anything and things like oh yeah these
guys they know what they're doing like
maybe it's a questionable higher with
Grigson if it were a good foundation of
a franchise you'd be okay I get it
they'll take a chance on the guy but
with Cleveland I just I'm kind of
questioning what they're doing yeah I
think it's gonna be a lot of eyes are
gonna be on Berry and see how he differs
from Dorsey and Sashi Brown he obviously
deserves you know a chance here before
we completely just you know jump on jump
down their throats before they make any
picks but there's gonna be a lot of eyes
on this new Cleveland team but having
miles Garrett back definitely is a huge
boost because when he's on the field he
is one of the best defensive players in
the entire league without a doubt I mean
last year before the suspension I think
we were talking about maybe he's become
the best d-end in football then the most
punchable quarterback in the NFL
causes him to rip his helmet off and
swing it out it happens now there was
some movement on the college landscape
that we have to talk about because well
number one because this is a football
podcast and we cover college football
but also because it could have a big
effect on the NFL Mel Tucker who was the
head coach of Colorado came out I
believe last week and said have not
taken the Michigan State job
Dantonio how suddenly were tired there
with some of the allegations going on
about paying recruits and all kinds of
stuff Mel Tucker says now I'm not
interested
Michigan State strikes out with a couple
other guys they come back to Mel Tucker
and say we're gonna pay you more than
anyone in the pac-12 can owe and we're
giving you six million dollars for your
assistance he wisely took the job I know
a lot of people are [ __ ] on Mel
Tucker for doing this I have no problem
with it if someone else offers you more
money you should take that job is unless
you're in like a great spot where you
don't want to do that I totally
understand now how this might affect the
NFL
Eric the enemy is the offense
coordinator the Kansas City Chiefs who
was famously a great running back at
Colorado Bakken back in the day Eric P
enemy is interviewed for seven NFL head
coaching jobs and has not received one
of them a lot of folks are now
speculating that he should go the
college route go take the Colorado job
prove that you can be a head coach and
then that will springboard you to an NFL
head coaching job I don't know where you
two stand on this but I completely
disagree with that if he wants to be the
head coach of Colorado he should do it
going to Colorado to be the head coach
is not a springboard to coaching in the
NFL guys I'm sorry it might be a
springboard to coaching at Florida like
Jim McElwain did but it is not you're
not gonna go from Colorado to the New
York Jets I mean even look her mad words
goes to Arizona State doing a hell of a
job no one's trying to hire him back
into the NFL lovie smith goes to
Illinois doing pretty good job no one
gives a [ __ ] Eric being me going to
Colorado that's how you get lost that's
not how you start over yeah I would
agree with that and I don't think that
that's what's gonna happen because I do
think that next year I think he's at the
top of the coaching candidates for next
year the next time it cycles around and
I think a lot of these guys that were
just hired we've seen a lot of coaches
here recently go one and done on their
coaching hires so I do think the Eric
vietname he's already interviewed for a
lot of these got these jobs a lot of
these guys are gonna be replaced next
year and I think that he's at the top of
the list I don't think I moved to
Colorado was gonna help him get his name
out there
or I don't think they're gonna see him
do let's say he goes to Colorado and
they go 12 or no I don't think people
are finally gonna say oh yeah you know
what Eric the enemy can't be a head
coach somewhere I think they're gonna
see him next year or that Kansas City
chief offense that is going to be good
like it doesn't matter what Eric V enemy
does the Kansas City chief offense will
be good next year that's I'll take my
bias hat off that's a fact
and his name's still gonna be relevant
because people are gonna say that
offenses really good the enemy's still
there maybe we should go get this other
Andy Reid disciple well and Doug
Peterson I'm at naggy a mixed success
Doug Peterson's won a Superbowl Matt
naggy was coach the year so I think
there's even a pressing at Conner your
team has Adam GaSe as head coach to
their Jets if case struggles like he did
this year I know they won some games
down the stretch but we all know that
was because of competition I'm Erik be
enemies got to be a dream higher for you
guys yeah they've interviewed him before
and I know a lot of people will say well
Mike mechag ninh did those interviews
the problem is the owner really did
those interviews and Christopher Johnson
so maybe he'll give him a second chance
before whatever reason the owner hired
Adam GaSe over Eric the enemy that has
not gone what that's gone exactly as you
would imagine
so yeah Hobie on the radar I would
assume again and also guys my question
here is you're the offensive coordinator
of the team that just won the Super Bowl
can easily win another one or two more
in the next couple of years is that not
a better job in coaching Colorado no no
insult to the fans of the Buffs around
here but that's not an easy gig you're
not strolling into Oklahoma
Ohio State Notre Dame you know a Legacy
Program with all these recruiting you
know easily recruiting spots so for me I
don't I think this is utterly ridiculous
I don't know why Eric the enemy would go
to Colorado to priya's nothing to prove
he's been an offensive coordinator on a
team that just won the Super Bowl like
you just alluded to Matt there are gonna
be plenty of jobs opening up after this
year one of those jobs could be the New
York Jets the place he's interviewed for
this guy doesn't need to prove anything
and I would like his job right now more
than a college head coaching job if I
was Eric the enemy and I think that's
what it'll come down to especially the
pac-12
the money in the packet elves not that
good which is a problem for them and we
we could spend a whole show talking
about how they need to get the TV deals
done so that they can pay like the big
12 an SEC do but right now and and the
Big Ten they're way behind and I would
say take a page out of the Scott frost
playbook sometimes it's better to like
be a legend at a school and just not
come back
I think Scott frost goes back to
Nebraska and we're all like oh my god
he's gonna get Nebraska back to being
the Blackshirts the corn Huskers they
have sucked
let your P enemy just be a legend to
Boulder for the rest of his life you go
back its what does they say you either
live long enough become a villain or you
die hero like just stay away I would say
I don't think Colorado's like I don't
want to offend the people of Colorado I
really like your program it's not like a
it's not a blueblood
it's not whatever we're gonna call that
next tier either like it's a really good
program you just lost you starting
quarterback you lost one of the best
player that's been through there in a
long time in Leviticus Channel that
program there's a reason why the coaches
are leaving like they are I'm with you
guys I would stay in Kansas City for
another year ride that out that offense
will be successful he's also left the
program twice for NFL jobs he went from
running backs coach there to an NFL job
at the Vikings and then he went from
offensive coordinator there to a running
backs coach job with Kansas City so the
writing's on the wall here guys he's had
opportunities at Colorado and he's
chosen to bet on himself at the NFL
level with lower lower level assistant
jobs so I don't know why he needs to
revert back to Colorado for a third time
when he's right on the cusp of getting
an NFL job that has wrongfully eluded
him recently if they want me to be head
coach though I would live in Boulder for
two and a half million dollars a year
sign me up sorry guys you are Paige Kuhn
can't come take my spot but the problem
is they weren't paying him two and a
half mil that's true he went one and a
half million I probably do it for that
too
I don't know the state income tax looks
like there how about Jameis get LASIK
we've joked about this as long as I've
known it happen you guys I mean he's
quits at the jumbo trying after every
interception finally it gets fixed and I
hope he got this for free because the
promotion and marketing possibilities
from Jameis squinting after every or
doing the the wide eye thing for watch
on YouTube
bet that impersonation was great and now
it's now me fixed now yes I'll say as a
person who has corrective lenses all
three of us do actually
it doesn't make you smarter with the
football you can see better but it
doesn't make your decision-making any
better did you say I know you guys saw
at night I wish I could remember who
tweeted it
they said Jameis went from 3031 II yeah
that Yates greatest field Yates did
great yes amazing tweet yeah I'm with
you though is it's not gonna help him
decide where to throw the football was
part of his problems due to vision we'll
see let's figure it out I'm glad that
you finally stopped being so stubborn it
was like you know what yeah let's give
this a try ten five as a guy that
doesn't like sharp objects being around
his eye like I kind of get not wanting
to do this but at the same time like
millions of dollars here on the line
might as well go get it fixed see what
you can do next year now if anything at
least work it into free agency now you
can be like oh well we fixed this vision
so Jameis is good to go this year he can
be your starting quarterback I do think
it would be funny if just by the luck of
the draw he cuts his turnovers in half
and everyone goes it was the LASIK it
just it feels like something like that
is gonna happen with Jameis this year
and it would be really really funny to
see you could has turnovers in half and
he still turns the ball over through its
great eyes a colorblind person I've
wondered if he's colorblind because I'm
not betting on any of that I just think
that he's he's a wild man yeah that's
how he plays he's a gunslinger guys all
right last bit of news and notes medical
marijuana passed in Ohio smoke him if
you got him but being a Browns or
Bengals fan is apparently not a good
enough reason to get medical marijuana
now I think you just need to spin that
into like anxiety depression yeah I
think they just tried to slip one in
there like what are the reasons that you
can get medical marijuana and somebody
was like what about being a Browns fan
would that be good enough and they're
probably let's go ahead and throw the
Bengals in there to trying to squeeze
one in but it didn't work I say good
effort on them though I mean I think
that being a sports fan in general
probably good enough of a reason for me
I have one last question for you guys
before we close out this segment because
they had the bleacher report office in
shambles today and the debate was and I
have very strong opinions on this but I
want yours could this year's LSU team be
the Vipers XFL team oh I think they
would I think I think they'd beat them
by two touched it I think they will us
you know who's on the Vipers XSLT
they're the supposed to be the worst XFL
team that's the reason for the debate
okay yeah it's LSU yeah I'm pretty sure
yeah now the Vipers yeah not good but or
any of the bad XFL teams yeah I mean I
know we have this argument a lot of
times with the NFL teams and I think
that's pretty ridiculous
but you look at the LSU roster and if
these guys aren't in the NFL and the
EXIF l still around I think it's pretty
safe to say that about 40 45 of them
could be on an XFL roster I mean this is
a really good team the quarterback Joe
burrow like you know that he's gonna be
at least Erin Murray which is a damn
good XFL player you know Clyde Edwards
Hilaire he's gonna be in the NFL that
skill position the offensive line yeah
I'm going with LSU and I'll even take
him like this year it suit him up right
now and I'm taking LSU and just 2020
I have 18 LSU players ranked I think
they got 16 invites to the combine these
are just numbers you never see and their
two best players might be underclassmen
in Jabbar that's the drinking we juniors
it's not just 18 players in this year's
draft is probably 12 and next year's
class I mean they have the best receiver
in the country and the best cornerback
in the country that aren't in this
year's draft I'm sorry I thought you had
another receiver in another corner that
will probably go first second round I
think I asked about the video the guy
punching the lady see when she reclined
I want to kill them both like no buck
right I'm firmly anti recline at all
times I think it's very inconsiderate
but that's not how you handle it number
one that's like the hottest debate on
the Internet
right
I remember the first time I flew with a
significant other and I had not flown
very much but as soon as we like leveled
out that seat went all the way back into
a larger man and I just looked at her
like the [ __ ] are you doing I'm gonna
have to fight this guy now because you
want to be comfortable for an hour and a
half no get your seat up happy
Valentine's Day will be back with cash
or trash NFL rumors it's time to play a
little game we call it cash or trash
good call Mel bringing this one back
this week this is where we tell you
rumors news notes even we can just say a
player's name and then we get to pick
cash or trash I'll go last let you guys
I get to play host on this one Tom Brady
to the Dallas Cowboys casual trash I'm
going trash with this one and I know
there are a lot of rumors out there with
where Brady will land I just don't think
it's the Dallas Cowboys specifically I
know that Andrew Magnussen listener of
the year would probably be ecstatic with
Tom Brady there's this quarterback I
just don't think the Dallas is the
landing spot just Tom Brady move on from
New England
I might go cash on that one I think that
Dallas gets a deal done with dak I think
that Michael Irvin is probably not a
credible source so I'm going trashy yeah
this one goes in the dumpster Tom
Brady's not playing for the Cowboys and
if that happens they've made a miserable
mistake you have a good young
quarterback and ascending young
quarterback and dak Prescott find a way
to get a deal done with him if you can't
you got a franchise and there's no other
option so I do like that Melo brought up
the counterpoint what would be you know
cash or trash Brady staying with the
Patriots and I maybe I'm getting fooled
by all these little rumors and feelings
but I'm starting to feel like Brady
might be leaving
he might be I don't know what do you
think Matt Jets fan wishful thinking
he's 43 10 years ago right I so i say
trash on brady to Dallas I think dak
Prescott is better than Tom Brady right
now
so I would keep dying Prescott I've
heard that he's staying but you know how
it is no one knows anything about New
England people are just talking out
their ass most the time right how about
this we guys Joe burrow does not want to
be a Cincinnati Bengal okay I am going
to lead this
I'm going straight cash on me like Randy
Moss on this one
I have even read some articles I've been
doing my research here on Tom Condon I
think that come April Joe burrow is
going to tell the Cincinnati Bengals
that he does not want to play for them I
know that there is not a lot out there
right now but I went back and I listened
to the Dan Patrick interview and he's
talking about I really want to go play
for a Super Bowl contender I want to be
drafted number one I didn't remember
anywhere in there where he said I want
to go to the Cincinnati Bengals he said
I want to go drafted number one to a
team that will contend for Super Bowls
and I think he was thrown some shade at
the Bengals I I know that you're not
paying for the scouting Department you
haven't been competitive in a really
long time and he's probably looking down
there in Miami with Coach Flores who got
what five wins this year with absolute
[ __ ] as a roster living on South
Beach yeah sign me up I spent a couple
days there for the Super Bowl and I
can't wait to get back so I'm going cash
on this one I do think that there's
something to this Joe burrow doesn't
want to go to Cincinnati thing I'm gonna
go trash and maybe internally Joe burrow
would prefer to not go to Cincinnati but
I don't think he's gonna come out and
really say anything I think he's just
gonna honestly
unfortunately deal with it now when you
look at him going to Miami instead chant
galleys back in the NFL boys and Chan
Gailey got a historic season out of Ryan
Fitzpatrick before with the Jets a 31
and 15 seasons so I think that would be
a good landing spot for Perot I just
don't think he hasn't he's saying it and
I just don't think he's the kind of guy
from a PR perspective that'll stand on
the table and say I'm not playing for
you like Eli Manning did many years ago
so I grew both you I I agreed Melo he
probably doesn't want to be a bangle but
like Connor said I think he's too good
of a person to say no but would you
expect that of Peyton Manning's little
brother though no I wouldn't but and
you're right I mean the Manning family
is very business savvy they're very
smart they knew it was going on with the
Chargers and they wanted to get to the
New York market ah who knows I'll say
this Tom Condon has been an agent as
long as I've been alive for a reason man
who played for the Kansas City Chiefs
little-known fact
and so
wouldn't be surprised if they were like
hey the Bengals are historically bad and
there's two ways to play it I think we
talked about this when the Browns had
the first pick you want that guy who's
gonna look at this city and say you're
gonna build a [ __ ] statue of me
because I'm gonna turn this thing around
I don't know who I don't know what the
Bengals would do that like with the
Browns it's this historic franchise with
the Bengals it's like ah Paul Browns
other team cool so I don't I'll say
trash on that one how about this one
guys Taysom Hill is a starting
quarterback in the NFL I think Jason
Hill is thrown like 13 passes in the NFL
Eston Mohamed Sanu I know that there has
been talk that it not talked Jason Hill
came on said if the Saints to a few mr.
franchise quarterback I might have to
leave this is a gentleman who for his
career is completed 40 6.2 percent of
his passes and that's not good
he has thrown he's thrown 13 passes
completed six
how many is he caught that was good
question 19 yeah yeah that's why I'm
going trasher at this one I like Taysom
Hill the dude tore up Texas when he was
at BYU did it with one leg even and I
love the way that the Saints used him I
love the way that he plays there's a
reason why he's out there running the
football and not prepared to be the
second string quarterback I mean he was
the third string guy behind Teddy
Bridgewater I don't think that the
Saints do want to move on from him but I
think mad it might've even been you that
was talking about maybe they just want
to drive up the cost for him yep so that
they can't keep him around for another
year or two see what's happening with
Drew Brees maybe give him some more
looks as a second string quarterback
when Bridgewater moves on to go
somewhere else but I'm just going trash
here I haven't seen enough from him to
even really say that he can play the
position let alone be a starter like he
might move on I don't know that there
are any teams in the league right now
saying I mean we got to go get taste
some hill he can change this franchise
around he can come be our starting
quarterback I think a lot of teams might
say we can go get Taysom Hill and see
what he's all about cuz nobody really
knows so I'm going trash I do not think
he's an NFL starter I'm with you guys as
well he's a great athlete I was looking
up I'm pretty sure at his pro day I mean
he's a four-four kind of guy almost a 40
inch vertical I mean he's a great great
athlete
that does not mean you're an NFL level
starting quarterback and I think some
people have gotten really you know drawn
into the fun gadgety plays and that he
plays special teams he can catch the
ball he'll complete a pass what once
every couple games oh I just think it's
a little ridiculous and good for Taysom
if he believes he's a starting
quarterback you can come out and say
that all you want but I'm just calling
it trash that other teams think you are
I agree that it is trash there are only
32 starting quarterback jobs in the NFL
I love Taysom Hill like Melo said all
the different ways he's used he seemed
like this awesome team first guy who
just you need me to block at the end
I'll do it you need me to run gunner on
punt team I'll do it
now it's started be like okay dude like
remember how you got here and and stay
in your lane a little bit so I'm gonna
say trash I don't think he's one of the
32 best quarterbacks in football is
where I was going at the top I don't
know he's one of the top 64 ooh we need
get Sims to worse yeah Blake board over
70 I want to see where where he has
tasted he'll how about this guy's cash
or trash Toa is healthy now to uh had
the CT scan earlier this week Connor and
I talked about it on the midweek show
Ian Rapoport reported that it looked as
good as could be range-of-motion was
there the fracture is healed cash or
trash that our guy to it is healthy and
I'm going trash on this one because who
released the report I'm sure it was an
agent you guys closed out the midweek
show talking about baseball and it's
almost baseball season so I'll throw
this nugget at you how many times have
we heard going into spring training
oh my gosh this player looks so great
he's lost so much weight he's gonna have
every year season ever
every year it's the same thing in the
NFL with every injured player oh god no
the break yeah it grew back stronger
he's fine ACL got 1 out of a pig he's
fine this is just agent speak this is
them getting their player hyped up so
I'm going trash here I think that hip is
probably [ __ ] and we need to really
look at it so until I see some combine
medicals I'm going trash because I'm not
believing what an agent's putting out to
Ian Rapoport or shefter or any of those
guys because they're feeding that
narrative of oh hey this is what the
doctor reported
is it though we don't know because it's
probably coming from an agent I'm sure
they didn't say here here's the medical
records take a look at it report
whatever you want because there's
probably some stuff in there there still
says oh we're you know we're still
looking at this flexibility's at that so
I'm going trash here until I see it from
unbiased doctors and unbiased reporters
I'm going trash man yeah no that's a
great point may change my mind on it no
I'm gonna go cash that he is on pace to
returning to full form a healthy I think
it's something that I said in the
midweek show the most important thing
with tua is right now do you believe he
can stay healthy because you can recover
from injuries but it's very often that
you could either re injure or - as a guy
that's been banged up in multiple spots
throughout his college career so that's
the most important note for me with - I
do think it almost feels like there's so
much hype right now that he's healthy
where you kind of turn your head and go
is this being hyped up this much for a
reason now are we starting to get a
little hyperbole involved but I'm a firm
believer that I'm no doctor that tua
will make a full recovery I think the
more important question for scouts GM's
betting their jobs on him do they
believe he can stay healthy over the
course of an NFL career or even an NFL
season that's what matters most right
now for two of because if none of these
concerns existed there would be a debate
between who should be the number one
pick him and Joe burrow and right now
there's no debate at all so yeah and
like I said Melo you did you laid out a
very strong argument there I had cash in
here just because I may be because I
want to believe that he is healthy me
too
I will go back to what I was told right
after the injury by someone who is a
doctor since the three of us aren't and
he said you know like fractures heal
like oh that's that's not the hard part
a fracture is gonna heal it was about
getting circulation to the femur so that
it didn't die basically it was continued
to have blood flow and again I I don't
understand all the medical stuff I was a
paramedic for about six months and
burnout so not my expertise so I know
where the femur is exactly I know you're
with the hip joint works but that's what
they're saying it's like the you know a
fracture is gonna heal over time there
was never a question of will the
fracture heal it was what does the hip
look like after that so I think again
Melo said it very very well I want to
see this from NFL team doctors not least
I'm Berg who is Jerry Maguire but
definitely has a biased and I hope that
too is healthy because Connor you're
talking about too and if this guy is
healthy he's probably my quarterback one
I love him play I think that mobility is
gonna be an issue after that hip because
I think that his mobility was a little
bit overrated I think we wanted him to
be this dual threat quarterback and he
wasn't but his ability of the football
would touch accuracy all over the field
I think was it was Drew Brees I still
have him comp to Drew Brees so I hope
that two is healthy and I'm rooting for
him hopefully after the combine we know
he is last one guys someone reported
that Matt Stafford was on the trade
block and they were like hey he's
getting traded to who I remember who
someone Tampa maybe anyway there's a
rumor the mast ever was on the trade
market cash or trash that Stafford is
truly on the trade market I'm going
trash I think that's just a lot of money
to move I easy on the trade market
probably I guess because who's not I
mean if you're making a lot of money you
have a back injury and somebody comes
around and says hey we'll give you a
first or maybe even a second yeah
they're probably gonna jump on it but I
just don't think that anybody is
offering to get Matt Stafford in there
right now
I think the Lions are probably right for
exploring that but I just don't think
anything's gonna happen with that
contract so when I read this in the
rundown I looked at it just says
Stafford trademarking I didn't know if
it was that does he have one or is he on
one so I think it's cash that he would
definitely have a good trade market
I think it's trashed that they're
trading him right now but I think it's
interesting for the Lions for two
reasons one being that you know we're
Stafford's helped that and do they want
to just blow this thing up and get a
good a good pick back right now because
I think you can get one yeah the
contracts big guys but if he's healthy
his cap number compared to what the
quarterback market is gonna be pretty
soon like if dak Prescott gets what the
37 million dollars a year and you have
Stafford who's hovering between I mean
he's all over the place he's between
like 22 and 33 it adds up fine but I
think also how many times the line is
gonna be picking in the top three maybe
they're one of the teams monitoring to
his health where they're sitting there
saying hey can we get a first for
Stafford right now
giraffe tua if we believe he's healthy
and use that extra first as a building
block for our roster that has plenty of
holes especially considering we'll see
what they do it's areas Schley coming up
so I'm fascinated by this I do think he
would have won I don't think they're
talking about it externally right now
with other teams it would cost them
thirty million dollars to not have him
on the team this year
see that's just you can't trade that
because I mean they have to pay that
even if they trade him so they're
knocking teams eat that money nah
it's so it's guaranteed I'm trying to
like scan this but basically his dead
cat value was 32 million dollars so even
if he were no matter what's happened
either it's a cut or a trade he would
cost thirty two million dollars on their
cap so he's he can't go anywhere
basically and I think to even to the
people who say like well they should
draft to a so you have a quarterback
who's broken his back two years in a row
and you're gonna draft a poor track
natured guy to bad ankles and a bad hip
not really the move for me in the NFC
North I don't like to in the NFC North
no that's like Teddy in the NFC North
not a great fit so I'm gonna say trash
on the fact that he could be traded
because it's just economically not
feasible okay let's take a break
top five is gonna be our top five 2017
draft these this one's gonna be fun cuz
it's not as predictable as you might
think we'll be back right after this we
are back on stick to football and we are
laughing because Melo called himself a
mewho mer like mahomes very slowly too
right it was good but everybody always
talks about or I don't know if you guys
see it as much as I do but they'll come
at you on Twitter because we talked
about the Kansas City Chiefs a lot and
it's not the fact that I'm Chiefs fan or
a mewho mer it's just that they're
really good at football so we talked
about yeah we talked about the Niners a
lot they
we're a throw from Jimmy G away from
winning a stick cycle that's bittersweet
so let's talk about the 2017 draft
instead we each pick our top five
draftees from that class someone who did
not make the list Solomon Thomas the
number three pick and that trapped hey
what about the number two did Mitchell
try Biscay the number two pick in the
draft so let's just get the the obvious
one out of the way all three of us put
Patrick mahomes at number one overall a
guy who went tenth in that draft the the
story has been told a million times Bret
Veatch falls in love with my homes
during his sophomore year at Tech
convinces Andy Reed he's the quarterback
to the future and E and then GM John
Dorsey execute the trade they move up to
number ten overall before the draft
started so a little bit of a ballsy move
they move up to number ten overall they
lie to me and says to take Jerrod Davis
which I tweeted out there you guys can
find it and mahomes fell right to their
lap so you're welcome brevich and John
Dorsey and Andy Reed for that you still
owe me but my home is number one I think
it's gonna it's not is every Brady at
199 but I think for a long time we're
gonna look back and say how the hell did
this guy go 10th yeah I think it's like
how did Jordan go 2nd are you third I
think I think we'll look back at it like
that - and I agree with you obviously
you're looking at this draft class from
2017 which was a very good one
mahomes is the Super Bowl MVP he's a
regular season MVP he's got to be one oh
yeah this what not really much left to
say now I will say I did this list in
like I tried to match up the value of
picks
I didn't just put saying the best
players on this list so miles Garrett
will not be on my list even though he
was worth the number one overall pick
but mahomes where he went
and considering he's the best player
he's the best football player on the
entire planet right now it's just a
no-brainer at number one for anyone you
can't make this list without him no no I
did my big board the complete opposite
way of you guys best players just
explain your picks and they'll make
sense so number two for me I went to
Shawn Watson another player who the
Texans traded up to draft him he was the
third quarterback selected in this class
III didn't warrant for what mahomes and
Lamar Jackson did this year we would be
talking so
much more about deshaun Watson who yep
he's one of my favorite players in the
NFL just the way he closes his poise
like you never feel like he's out of a
game unless his defense you know gives
up a twenty four point lead at Arrowhead
which has happened before so I Watson's
just amazing I think you know we're
blessed to see this new age of
quarterback coming in and the fact that
these two guys to both come out the 2017
class and neither of our teams drafted a
quarterback that year Connor so that's a
little bit bittersweet he had good times
Cleveland Browns basically got fired
because of this draft because they
didn't take one of these guys but I
think the Shaun Watson you know unfairly
doesn't get the credit he deserves
nationally because you know first it was
oh my god Baker Mayfield and now it's
you know Pat and Lamar Watson deserves a
ton of praise as one of the best chef
quarterbacks in the league yeah I think
outside of my home's he's probably my
second favorite quarterback in the NFL
right now I love to watch him play he's
my number two guy as well and you know I
think right before this draft we kind of
started looking at the quarterback
position saying man these guys coming
out of the spread offense they just
can't play in the NFL like we thought
they could it's not transitioning to the
NFL guys like golf and wins we're
getting drafted again but then this
group came along and it's like oh holy
[ __ ] wait a second yeah you can't come
from a spread offense in college and be
very successful in the NFL and these
guys are doing it Watson and mahomes I
think that's gonna be I don't really
want to call it a rivalry because it
seems like there's so much mutual
respect there but I think that's a
showdown that we're gonna see a lot of
with the Texans and Watson and the
Chiefs in mahomes I agree I think that'd
be great for football watching those two
go head to head for a long time number
two I went a different direction
I went George Kittel here pick one 46 in
that draft I think he's the best tight
end in football yes 85 catchers and
catches are more in both of his last
season's over a thousand yards in both
of his last seasons he's an incredible
blocker he's an incredible team a it
just doesn't get better than that
I mean fifth round pick 146 Pro Bowler
George Kittel is phenomenal it's
probably to be honest with you guys it's
probably the best pick of that 49ers era
under John Lynch in terms of value and
talent
I'm just unbutton in my shirt over here
that is [ __ ] that's a ring you better be
a doodle doesn't have one I love weed so
the only thing that we actually argue
about anymore that real is a real
argument is George Kidal vs. Travis
Kelce I had a feeling yeah I love George
Kittel he's obviously he's he's the
second best tight end in the NFL and I
know that we have so many 49er friends
that are just gonna try to eat my lunch
over Twitter you're not gonna change my
mind I love the guy he's an exceptional
blocker I still think that Travis Kelce
for this year was still better Titan so
number three on my list I went Christian
McCaffrey here and and like Connor and
Melo said you guys did your list a
little different differently so what I
looked at this it was McCaffrey went
eight which was at the time people like
I can't believe the drafting a small
running back in the top ten look at him
now the guy's an all-pro I think he's
the best running back in football
oh and he's gonna add a thousand yards
as a receiver every year but the fact
that he went I mean Solomon top mid
strabinsky Solomon Thomas Leonard
fournette Corey Davis and Mike Williams
went ahead of him like Jamal Adams going
to the Jets at six
I loved Jamal I was back in that pick
all day with the fact that McCaffrey who
should have won a Heisman Trophy at
Stanford went this late the guy has just
been if you can say a top 10 pick has
been disrespected McCaffrey has been
disrespected every step of the way from
Stanford even to now when people talk
about Oh best running backs it's dare
Terry and Nick Chubb [ __ ] no it's not
it's Christian McCaffrey is adding 2,000
yards every year to that offense how is
Christian McCaffrey not you know there's
that little thing like pick a
quarterback running back receiver that
you know it's like huh how is anyone not
picking Christian McCaffrey I I really
like Christian McCaffrey too so I agree
with you he didn't make my list because
you're crazy because I did it
differently I went with like two top
five guys I would like to have from that
draft which is why number three for me
is Miles Garrett because he's a pass
rusher and I think the positional value
goes there instead of a running back so
I love Christian McCaffrey what I love
to have him on my team of course but I
think to win games you have to
get after the quarterback we talked
about miles Garrett he's reinstated
which means he is one of the best edge
rushers in the NFL in Cleveland
dominating the AFC North I love the guy
when were talking about chase young this
year the standard that he's held against
has been Miles Garrett well is he miles
Garrett out is he compared with this
because that's what miles Garrett he's
the prototypical pass rusher and he's
been productive productive so I gotta
take him here at 3:00 I know you guys
kind of did your boards differently but
if I'm looking back at that draft class
and you say okay take five guys Miles
Garrett's gonna be one of them for
anything all five of them
fro well I like that we did it
differently because it should I mean
you're not getting the same list over
and over again you're getting you know
the top five players that you'd want the
top five value picks and then Matt did a
little bit of mix of both so for me here
at number three it's deshaun Watson you
guys both had him at two I mean the
Texans they did have to trade up to get
him but he's so good you got him at 12
the league over thought this guy there's
no other way around it it's unbelievable
how much they overthought him I guess it
was concerns over injuries which did
happen early on in his career there but
he's the type of quarterback they can go
out and win you games on his own and
he's done that at times all world
character and leader but also or all
world talent and I as long as he could
stay healthy
besides my homes this could go down as
the best pick of this entire 2017 draft
especially when you think that the
Browns got Jabril Peppers like that was
what they did with that pick good job
guys number four for me my man Alvin
Kamara
still one of the best interviews we have
ever had on stick to football he is a
unique personality this past year I
think people forgot a little bit how
great Kumar is because of injury but he
fell all the way to 67 overall New
Orleans trades up with San Francisco so
thanks again to my team for not taking
not only did you hope for Watson you
didn't take Alvin Kamara thank God the
fifth round pick that we're gonna get to
in a little bit save the draft for them
but Kamara when healthy is just such a
stud I think he and McCaffrey are
exactly what we look for when we
evaluate running backs now you know with
John Drury Swift guys like that it's you
got to be able to catch the ball you got
to have inside outside zone
Kamara is the total package when he's
healthy yeah and you really like running
backs
I like pass rushers so I'm going with TJ
watt well not if I was building a team
right well I'm going with TJ why you
talk about another guy that's not really
getting the respect that he deserves
TJ Watt has been exceptional and I know
that a lot of people wanted to talk
about him because he is the younger [ __ ]
brother and I can relate to that but
he's also the better wot brother and I
can also relate to that 14 and a half
sacks last season thirteen sacks the
year before that this guy is shining
well people aren't recognizing because
that goddamn popular older brother that
he has but TJ watt is a great edge
rusher one of the best in the league
fell to the Steelers I think is a great
fit there and a great player you were
Derek watt if you're wise you never want
to be Derek number for Eddie Jackson for
me this goes back to my argument with
Kido
Eddie Jackson was taken in the fourth
round pick 112 and all he's really done
is made plays especially a second year
in the league when he really broke out
six interceptions two forced fumbles he
actually brought two of the
interceptions back to the house on pick
sixes so to get a free safety like Eddie
Jackson that late in the giraffe that
was a phenomenal pick by the Bears and
you know one of the reasons
Ryan pace probably still has a job to be
honest with you when you can get a guy
like that that late at the safety
position for now for now for now Admiral
resurface again that you know what's
funny about that tweet he's gone the
full cycle of I know it's amazing
it might be there's my favorite tweet
ever on Twitter because you know that so
the famous tweet right after the Bears
draft a good friend of mine who is very
high in an ad for front office texted me
and said Ryan pace just got fired with
this draft and I said can I tweet that
he's like [ __ ] yes you can so I did it's
funny because then people assigned it to
me making it my opinion it was like what
nope it's it quotes not me and then Ryan
pace was the exec of the year and people
are like your friends an idiot he should
be fired
now Ryan pace not as good of his job and
people are like hey is that exact
available to me in our new GM it's my
favorite tweet ever number five for me
though the guy who has probably saved
John Lynch's job at least in terms of
drafting is George
Krieger Kittel our guy from Iowa so I
loved him in the draft I know connor was
working with me that weekend 17 trapped
i was like literally texting teams on
day three like draft george kiddo like
what what are we waiting for
he goes around 5:00 to the niners
incredibly happy for him because he did
land in a great fit he's an athlete he's
a blocker he is a super-sized
personality which I love that we're
getting that from the Titans in the NFL
now it's not this Jay Novacek boring
stuff anymore I'm a George kiddo guy
two-time Pro Bowler all-pro the last two
years I personally think he's the best
tide in a football because he gives you
a lot more yards after catch ability I
will say Kelsey's better in the red zone
but George Kittel at 1:46 one of the
bigger steals in the draft and oh by the
way a guy who went to high school in
Norman Oklahoma did not go to Oklahoma
he went to Iowa so I like him for that
too yeah smart man that's what it sounds
like to me
number five for me I'm going what Rene
BIA sweet the Buffalo Bills traded the
number ten overall pick that the Kansas
City Chiefs used to draft Patrick
mahomes and nobody talks about oh my god
the bills are so stupid they passed on
Patrick Holmes that's because they got
an elite cornerback intraday vyas white
in place of him and some other kick back
picks as well so a very good move by a
guy who's developing into one of the
best corners in football last year had
six interceptions looks like he is on
pace to be one of those guys that you
know we start talking about best corners
in the NFL I think in a couple years a
year or two
today vyas White's names gonna be up
there yeah I was very torn very torn
between Trey white and my number five
player Jamal Adams I went with Jamal
Adams cuz I'm a Jets fan that all I do
on the show is praise everything the
bills do under Brandon bean so I took a
break for that for one segment and go
with Jamal Adams at number five I mean I
really think he was the best safety in
football this year while Derwin James
was her Earl Thomas you know coming back
and it wasn't exactly himself still a
really good player but this opened the
door for Adams to establish himself as
the best
safety in football which I think he has
and like you said Melo I think for tre
white yeah he's a guy that's trying to
establish himself as the best corner and
he's not far behind Steph Gilmore so
when you look at both these guys in the
secondary in the AFC East they were
great picks that year a lot of fun the
2017 draft was who was we need to do
this I think over the summer and I know
I always say oh they certainly need to
do this I want to start going back and
grading drafts especially ones that
we've all worked not just making fun of
my 2013 Luke Joe Cole love but like you
know digging into like 16 17 I mean
reading some drafts Marshawn Lattimer
Marlin Humphrey were in this draft we
talked about them Budda Baker I really
like butta Baker Calvin Dalvin cook in
this draft I'm three really good running
backs Joe Mixon yeah it's a good draft
and then you have the Niners getting
samba Thomas Ruben Foster
there you go Oh Jay Howard hasn't lived
up to the hype we had for him and it's
it was a weird year a really weird year
it was all right let's take a break
draft on draft is up right after this it
is draft on draft time man I really
should have grabbed beer tonight for
draft on draft because dry February
lasted till the 13th and it started on
like the sixth so go be true hey I have
I've not had a beer all week go me so
first question here's the guy who needs
a beer no name on this one what is your
take on how to deal with a breakup this
is not me just lost my college
sweetheart of three years in your
podcast feels like the only thing to
look forward to every week number one
ham we're sorry but number two you're
welcome that we could be there for you
through this time so I've actually only
been broken up with once and it was when
my wife left me for the landlord that's
true sick brag right that's true story I
was there it happened yeah but I think
the move is you fight him hi I would
happen he was 40 years old I didn't want
to break his hip so that's I heard 23 he
was 40 come on so what I would say is do
like you're doing with the podcast
surround yourself with you know with
friends with things that make you happy
it feels like every time I go through a
breakup I just start buying random [ __ ]
if you can do that
I recommend it it's a lot of fun yeah I
mean even when I'm happy so I wish I
could yeah get on your guys level I
attached myself to friends like when I
got divorced my wife slept with a
co-worker and I just started hanging out
with friends and drinking a lot which I
don't recommend you do because not
everybody handles their alcohol like I
do I drink a lot because when I drink I
get incredibly happy some people when
they drink get really depressed and down
or angry don't do that That's not me
when I drink I get happy so find what
makes you happy for me it was going out
and getting hammered ass drunk with my
buddies so find what makes you happy and
just do more of that I would say embrace
your freedom that you have because
anybody who's ever been in a
relationship male or female you know
that you don't have a whole lot of
freedom just go run with that you have
all the freedom you do whatever you want
right now and enjoy it I was gonna say
if this person has been in a
relationship since college I mean use
this time as the first time in your life
as an adult to go do what you want
like if you're in like a serious
relationship since college you have no
idea what it's like to just go do
whatever the hell you enjoy also you
know what I don't know what fields you
work in but it's a good time to maybe
put more focus on work and fun so I know
it's hard to sit there and say oh this
is a positive but there's a lot of
positives you could take from that as
well especially this person's talking
about their college sweetheart I would
imagine they're pretty young yeah I mean
I got married around that age and and it
did not last long thanks to that
landlord but I will say I didn't know we
didn't do baby right I didn't know
myself and so you know you might be in a
similar spot where now you can go do the
things that you enjoy
do you ever send him a thank-you card uh
no I do see him occasionally because
they still live in town and he's old now
yeah I mean right you know they had a
couple kids together I think they're
happy you know good for them it wasn't a
good fit I would not have guy and scheme
fit exactly bad good player bad scheme
would not have got to where I am right
now with same if I've been in that
marriage I think you can take that
advice
- because looking back on it at the time
when we both got cheated on it was like
oh my god this sucks this is so terrible
now I see my ex-wife all the goddamn
time and I want to go up to that guy and
shake his hand and guy you know what
you've given me the best four years of
my life man
thank you very much you took all this
pressure off of me you freed up every
other weekend for the rest of my life I
owe you so much I might hug him the next
time all right Troy Crawford with a
football question what do you think the
Chiefs could get in return for Chris
Jones would it be similar to what they
gave up to get Frank Clark last year I
think that's a really good example if
they do the tag and trade on Chris Jones
I think the conversation starts at a
first rounder and it could get more
complicated it could get to you know
first in a second and you kick back a
third or there's a lot of different ways
to structure this deal but if that's the
route the Chiefs go and I'm starting to
lean that way and think that that's what
they do then I think you can look at the
Frank Clark trade and say okay this is
what works last year chief said uh 2019
first the Seahawks sent back a second I
believe I'm trying to find this deal and
to have the exact details but I think
that's a pretty good look at it because
if you're Seattle's well those teams
actually even make sense to do this with
Seattle will then have to sign Chris
Jones so you usually don't get as much
back like the Chiefs wouldn't get as
much back because they know that Seattle
then has to sign him so yeah it was
Seattle got a first rounder the Chiefs
second rounder and a swap a third-round
pick so it was actually a lot damn that
is it's a big cost I think you're
probably right that's the starting point
I don't think there are many teams in
the top of the first half and the first
round that are gonna be after Chris
Jones but you start to look at some of
these teams that are picking late in the
first round like the Seahawks that maybe
say okay yeah we'll take a chance on a
guy like Chris Jones who still very
young and very productive in the league
and I think the Chiefs are going to look
at and say wait we can fill two of our
holes in the first round or we'll use
that to move up to get one of these
really good corners or
to be in play for patrick queen i think
that this is kind of a win-win for
everybody except for chris jones who
won't get to win the Super Bowl next
year I think it would be really hard for
me as a GM to execute a trade for a
franchise tag player in this state of
football you would have to be in like a
situation where you just have in
abundance of CAP space that you're not
even gonna hit the cap floor because to
give up those kind of assets for a
player and get a player that is not on a
rookie deal that needs to get paid like
Chris Jones is gonna get 180 million
dollars guys yeah I mean he's gonna
probably close to 20 a year yeah so I
think if the chief should definitely tag
and trade him if they're not gonna keep
him but on the flip side of it I
personally would not often trade for
tagged players because it's a double
whammy in terms of how much you're
giving up money and picks the Miami
Dolphins have 94 million dollars in cap
space they have a perfect example in
round one and Chris Jones is from
Mississippi mind you I was close I
almost had it but they should that's a
good thing you consider it if they trade
26 for Chris Jones yeah I mean probably
more than that but this guy this Highway
25 almost 26 he's still young I also
don't know if Kansas City is gonna be as
eager to move on from him as everybody
thinks he is this guy was exceptional in
the Superbowl when healthy I mean he was
banged up all year so you can look at
his stats and say oh man he he had a
down year this year I mean the guy was
injured he was playing hurt a lot and
still had nine sacks this season two in
the regular season yeah play right and
then I mean just the year before 2018
guy had 15 and a half sacks I think he's
probably the number two interior
defensive lineman in the entire NFL
right now there could be a marker for
him if the Chiefs do want to move on
yeah and to your point I think there's a
lot of people like Oh Sammy Watkins has
gone Chris Jones is gone I think we
might see a an effect here where people
want to play in the homes and they want
to win Super Bowls because you know that
like you're not making the Hall of Fame
without a couple Super Bowl rings and
things like that so I I think there's a
it's gonna be a draw to keep people in
Kansas
next question from justice Straub out of
the current top five players on your big
board who would you be most and least
surprised to see bust in the NFL so my
top five actually have to pull up
because I have a million tabs open and
none of them chase young Joe burrow Jeff
Okuda Jerry Judy Isiah Simmons I would
be least surprised if Isiah Simmons
busted because he is a great athlete but
he does not have a true position and I
know I'm not saying he's a bad player
obviously it's number five overall we've
said before his position should be
defense but if he goes somewhere where
they don't know how to use him I think
Simmons could be a guy that were like
James remar Aaron curry yeah oh you like
forced it looks like it looked like he
was he was like a lock to be knock
terrible and so with Simmons it's like
man if he went some over they didn't
know how to use him I could see him not
working out and that's actually why I'm
gonna say I love Isiah Simmons I could
see him being a bust I could see the New
York Giants drafting him and not
protecting him with good defensive line
player just plugging him in at middle
linebacker in it not working out because
I think the one hole in his game is he
doesn't disengage from blockers
exceptional ability to read the offense
and use his athleticism to make tackles
and sacks and interceptions but I think
of a team just sits there and plugs him
in at middle linebacker we could see a
couple years where he's just not very
productive because that's not the role
that he's used to playing and uh
sometimes you get a guy and you draft
him to play a different position than
way he's used to but I really think that
the right situation is gonna make or
break Isiah Simmons much more than it
will any of these other guys much more
than it would you know Jerry Judy or
Derrick brown or Jeff Okuda because that
linebacker there's so many different
roles that he could play or maybe a team
drafted even says alright now you're a
safety let's cut some weight in play
safety full-time so I'm gonna say most
likely to bust out of my top five I'm
gonna say Isaiah Simmons my top five is
chase Young Joe burrow Jeff Okuda Jerry
Judy and tua and the answers obvious
unfortunately it's two of because of
long-term injury concerns and I love to
his talent and it goes to show you how
much I love to his talent I still have
him as the
the overall player but I mean guys would
anyone be surprised if it ends up being
a Sam Bradford kind of situation yeah I
mean in three years I wouldn't be
surprised if he has to be out of the
league yeah I would hate that to happen
but you just can't sit here and act as a
prize and then I it's tough man I feel
good about some players in this class
like I feel really good about a kuda
transitioning Sam Judi I actually do you
guys do you guys think Judy's the safest
player in this class I think chase young
is I worst case scenario chase Young is
gonna get after the quarterback his
weakness is run support
worst case scenario he's the speed
rusher who's gonna get home so yeah but
I think it's like I young a CUDA and
Judy are incredibly safe because Judy
has been so overthought in this process
I know it's like I he had to body catch
or body drops if people like oh I can't
catch no sir the man can catch he's fine
and I has a bad game and people start
dropping him down the board yeah yeah
he's solidly up there for me so if I had
to pick what I would be most surprised
if chase Young busted and I say that
even knowing I think outside a
quarterback edge rusher does bust the
most but he's man I was Laura's miles
Garrett yeah I mean watching him play
and we didn't get to see Nick Bosa in
his junior year at Ohio State so we
can't compare it there but what chase
young did his junior year at Ohio State
was one of the best offensive seasons
I've ever seen for watching college
football for the last 30 years I really
don't expect chase young to bust I think
that he's gonna be a guy that makes a
couple Pro Bowls probably leads the
league in sacks at least once if not
more than that I just don't see a world
where chase young is a bust
yeah he's been is undervalued I know
it's crazy to say but he's been
undervalued all right this next question
from Eamonn Morrissey had he been
healthy with Dylan Moses have been
ranked higher than Isiah Simmons nope
and I like tille Moses a lot and when we
thought he was gonna come back I think
he was in my top 12 I would still look
at dole Moses and say this guy who's
been pretty banged up
and I think had we had more time to get
into his tape
you'd have correct 2018 I think there
would have been enough deficiencies and
not the elite athleticism he doesn't
move like Simmons no some of us just
preference like I think Dylan Moses
would have been pretty close to Devin
Bush for me as a prospect's like really
good linebacker but not I'm stealing
this I saw it on reddit which I usually
read for conspiracy theories but I
thought about the draft they called the
guy a presidential prospect so like
every four to eight years you know a guy
comes around that's special
I think the isaiah simmons athleticism
is that you know you were deciding you
see guys like that hell we can't even
compare him to anybody you know he's so
rare you can barely figure out what
position the guy is actually a plane i
think that one of my super talents is
actually being able to watch clemson and
finding isaiah simmons very quickly i'm
getting very good at it because i just i
keep going back and watching the guys
film like i I think I'm finally starting
to diagnose it so as far as you know
some of the other linebackers go like a
Dylan Moses I don't know what Dylan
Moses could have shown us this year to
catch Isaiah Simmons because Patrick
Queen was very good and we're not
talking about him in the Isaiah Simmons
mold yet
Kenneth Murray made like every tackle
for Oklahoma and we're not talking about
him I mean that guy's ridiculously fast
he weighs in at 230 pounds he's just not
Isiah Simmons and that's nothing against
any of these guys they all I think
probably first-round linebacker talent
Isaiah Simmons is just the unicorn which
we've been calling him for a while now
there's this comp a unicorn all right
Jeremy Galton last question is this
year's running back class low key deeper
than the wide receiver class II not for
me yeah I say it's deep but it's not
that deep
I think the running back class actually
I have as my ranking sorted if my page
would stop freezing I have so many wide
receivers listed as draftable running
back for me dries up a little bit after
like Keyshawn Vaughn it's like the top
hundred players at running back or the
running backs in my top hundred are all
really good but after that like I like
Javan leak but I'm not like super
excited about him so I mean he's my one
two three four or five or six seven
he's my eighth running
my eighth wide-receivers a first rounder
so that's what I was gonna say like I
love the four top running backs swift
Chandler Dobbins Edwards Hilaire I
really like all those guys and I think
they could be very productive in the NFL
that's my top four you go to my number
five receiver you got guys like justice
Jefferson Justin Jefferson Shane all ham
lured anuman peoples Jones IU Kevon
Jefferson there's a lot of really good
receivers in this class is the
runningback class deep yeah like those
four guys are exceptional I think any
one of them could be the number one
running back in a given class but this
receiver class is probably the deepest
position group I've ever seen I do think
it drops off differently you know you
said those four guys Melo I would add
cam akers into that group yeah but after
that it's you make a great point that
the wide receivers it doesn't drop off
like that I mean we sit there and we
keep tearing them right you have Judy CD
lamb I think rogue's is almost in that
top tier as well but then you get into
this it's crazy t Higgins Justin
Jefferson ylvis' kishan all but then you
get into like some people are gonna
value because they value speed KJ Hamlin
Jalen Rieger in those in that backend
around one as well or early round two
Donovan people's Jones after the combine
people's heads are gonna explode and
they're gonna back why didn't this guy
do more Michigan the show has been
telling you for years that Shea Paterson
sucks and that's why so get Donovan
peoples Jones into that conversation I
don't have the same feeling with the
running back group there will always be
guys on day three some of even the
smaller guys like JJ Taylor and Anthony
mcFarland somebody will shake out from
that pack and be a really nice player
but wide receiver is is unusually
ridiculous this year I have ten
receivers of my top fifty overall
players in 19 of my top 100 I've never
ever seen anything like that and I'm I
like the thing I'm a pretty tough critic
when it comes to receivers this year is
just it's special so let me ask a
follow-up question then because the
history of the NFL Draft we can usually
figure out like okay this many receivers
usually get drafted this many
quarterbacks usually get drafted in the
first round do you think we're just
gonna see an extreme outlier for a
number of receivers they get drafted
this year not in the
first round but just seven I know I
still think it'll be right around 30 to
35 yeah which I mean sucks because there
are guys like you scroll down the list
there's you guys like like marques
Calloway from Tennessee most years if
the all fields good that guy probably
it's drafted I don't he does this year
Omar Bayless Arkansas State ton of
production he might not get drafted so
it's I can't see forty two receivers
getting drafted like how many people
want to happen yeah I think the number
spikes on day two like last year on day
two
there was only eleven receivers drafted
I think it'll be higher this year I
agree and I say only eleven I think
that's actually a lot because when you
go back to the year before that there
was only eight receivers drafted on day
two yep and lastly the receiver run
started a little bit late so I think
this year it starts earlier but I mean
we've talked about there's gonna be a
decent amount of quarterbacks drafted
this year which is nice and nestled
think there's gonna be did you say
quarter quarters and corner I think
there's gonna be four quarterbacks taken
in the first round yeah
so me to imagine if Eason sneaks in yeah
I mean he could at the back in the first
round I don't even think it would be a
surprise
no even shock me if it happened on draft
night what if Jalen Hertz goes round one
I hope it does I think I mean we'll tear
it apart but I hope it I don't have and
Rashad penny in the first round that's
what that would be thrill it I've
learned my lesson about being surprised
just my lesson is don't ever be
surprised Raptor didn't they'll probably
invite him to the draft alright that is
our show again no show Monday enjoy
Presidents Day spent a day thinking
about your favorite president who guys
favorite president you have one Obama
yeah same with me
I haven't been alive for that many yeah
I really must admit like I didn't mean
just that you were alive for Justin Matt
not all of us read only the ones I was
around for and Obama power ranking
number one I don't want to roll like a
name out there and be like wait this guy
really [ __ ] up and I he was for
slavery and
like oh I just thought he was got a cool
name you say Andrew Jackson people are
like look what he did to the Native
American oh yeah you got to be careful
mine would be FDR so apparently this is
a very liberal podcast to Obama's than
an FDR we'll be back Wednesday to talk
to you guys then